my wife and I are two months away from
the birth of our first child that's
[__] awesome congratulations I want
to hear your opinion on one of the names
we have been favoring first name birdie
[__] you you're not naming a kid birdie
you're full of [__] yeah I don't I don't
buy this last name starts with a g her
initials would be b-u-g bug is this too
weird of a name ow you [__] hipster
[__] no it isn't go ahead and name your
[__] baby birdie you [__] dope I
imagine the DMV calling her name or a
teacher calling her name and roll call
what do you think you know what I think
you know name a kid birdie you're
literally giving people a reason every
[__] day to [__] with your kid why
would you do that give her a pretty name